[Music]
searching for a ship or airplane in the
ocean is technically more challenging
than going into space you're essentially
dealing with one atmosphere of pressure
when we go to 6 000 meters were dealing
with pressures that would crush you
i'm steve cena ward the co-founder of
eclipse group in a subsea explorer we
specialize in ultra deep water search
and recovery when we go out on an
operation we find crashed ships or
airplanes in the ocean then upon finding
them we recover the object
over the course of my 32-year career i
participated in 100 plus high-profile
search and recovery operations like air
france 447 and a number of military
aircraft
the reason these investigations occur is
to prevent the future loss of life
pulverizing steve say tomorrow speaking
the first step is receiving the phone
call
when we get the call we go out with the
ship we deploy the side scan sonar to
search the area where we think the
object is
upon finding it we would deploy the
remote operated vehicle which would go
down recover the object and all the
information that's collected by the
vehicle
we're getting the results that
information real time and after
everything that we have to go through to
assemble the equipment go out perform a
search
when it finally breaks the surface of
the water it's a phenomenal feeling it's
even better when you get it onto the
deck of the ship the proof's there that
you've done your job right
[Applause]
[Music]
as a kid you want to make a difference
you want to you know find and discover
new things and tell people about them
and that really was you know the driving
force
i grew up spending the rest of my life
exploring the oceans
now i'm living my dream and every day is
a unique challenge and an adventure
[Music]
you